puedes andar en bicicleta un quinto de
milla por minuto vamos a marcar este
quinto de milla un quinto de milla por
minuto si te toma tres minutos y un
tercio de minuto llegar a la casa de tu
amigo
cuál es la distancia entre tu casa y la
de tu amigo bueno como pueden ver aquí
tenemos varias imágenes extras que
buscan bueno seguramente ni siquiera
están yendo ni siquiera están montando
su bicicleta adecuadamente sin embargo
bueno está divertido ver cómo manejan
sus bicicletas estos señores con otras
funciones pero lo hacen horas de regresa
con el ejercicio resulta que tenemos un
quinto de milla por minuto y esa es la
velocidad con la que nosotros logramos
andar y normalmente nos toma tres
minutos un tercio de minuto para llegar
a la casa de nuestro amigo así es que
veamos vamos a tener un quinto
por tres minutos un tercio como vamos a
manejar esta información nosotros vamos
a reescribir este tipo de fracciones así
es que tendremos un quinto
multiplicando
este tres minutos un tercio realmente
significa tres minutos más un tercio
estamos de acuerdo así es que aquí
podemos aplicar la propiedad
distributiva y haremos lo siguiente
multiplicaremos un quinto
por 3
este primer 3 y en este caso este 3 lo
que realmente representa es un 3 sobre 1
si tú tienes un número entero no puedes
siempre poner como fracción como ese
mismo número sobre 1
a eso le sumaremos un quinto
por un tercio vamos a mantener los
mismos colores para que sea claro y
entonces vemos que tenemos unas
multiplicaciones y unas sumas aquí
aplicaremos lo que es el orden de las
operaciones recuerda que primero van las
multiplicaciones y después haremos la
suma tomaremos esta primer
multiplicación donde tendremos un quinto
por tres enteros o tres sobre uno y aquí
lo que haremos es multiplicar el
numerador por numerador 1 por 3 sobre
denominador por denominador 5 por 15 por
1 y este será nuestro primer paréntesis
ahora haremos el siguiente un quinto por
un tercio a este primer resultado le
sumaremos un quinto por un tercio
numerador por numerador
uno por uno
sobre denominador por denominador 5 por
y de esta forma podemos llegar a nuestro
primer paréntesis 1 por 3 es igual a 3 5
por 1 es igual a 5
a tres quintos le sumaremos uno por uno
15 por 315
a tres quintos le sumaremos un 15 hago
esto parece un sexto de verdad vamos a
marcarlo un poquito mejor para que se
vea que es un quinto
un quinto
nosotros buscaremos un denominador común
y en este caso el 15 es divisible entre
5 y entre 15 así es que tomaremos el 15
como nuestro denominador común y
tendremos algún resultado sobre 15
si nosotros queremos ver este tres
quintos en términos de 15 a bosch
multiplicaremos tanto el numerador como
el denominador por 3 y con eso podremos
tener nuestro tres quintos en una
fracción equivalente vista en términos
de 15 años tendremos entonces 3 x 39
5 por 3 15
915 a vos
más un quinceavo vamos a mantener los
mismos colores para que sea mucho más
visual y con esto ahora sí tenemos una
suma de 15 a 29 15 años más un quinceavo
es igual a 10 15 a vos
y esta fracción aún puede ser
simplificada ya que tiene tanto el 10
como el 15 un factor común que es el 5
si nosotros dividimos 10 entre 5 nos
dará 2 15 entre 5 es igual a 3 podemos
decir entonces que nuestro amigo vive a
dos tercios de milla de nuestra casa y
aquí pueden ver que hice toda una
historia para poder llegar a este
resultado sin embargo vamos a pensar si
existe alguna otra posibilidad de
hacerlo y si existe vamos a hacerlo aquí
arriba tenemos entonces un quinto el
cual multiplicará tres enteros o un
tercio para que nosotros volvamos a este
número mixto una fracción impropia lo
que haremos es reorganizar lo donde el 3
es igual a 9 tercios
y el un tercio se queda aquí
si hacemos esta suma tendremos un quinto
que será multiplicado a nueve tercios
más un tercio diez tercios
y podemos hacer entonces la
multiplicación directamente tendremos
numerador por numerador 1 por 10
sobre denominado denominador por
denominador
5 x 3 y de esta manera podemos hacer
nuestra multiplicación donde 1 por 10 es
igual a 10
y 5 por 3 es igual a 15 que es
exactamente estos 10-15 abós que
habíamos visto abajo y que si dividimos
entre el factor común que es 5 tendremos
dos tercios
de esta manera llegamos también a la
respuesta correcta donde nuestro amigo
vive a dos tercios de milla de nuestra
casa